good morning done today I'm gonna tell
you a bunch of jokes that are gonna make
you go hahaha but you really you're
gonna enjoy you're gonna pretend like
you don't enjoy but you're gonna like
I'm planning on beating my previous
record that will require 52 jokes in
less than four minutes let's go what do
you call a five-foot psychic that's
escaped from jail a small medium at
large
why did the mermaid wear seashells cuz
she girl out of her B shells what
concert cost 45 cents City set featuring
Nickelback how did the hipster burn his
tongue he drank coffee before it was
cool what is invisible it smells like
carrots rabbit farts what do you call a
fake noodle an imposter what do you get
when you crossed the Atlantic with the
Titanic about halfway how does Jack
Frost get to work by icicle bicycle but
I think out of the face of BOE go to the
party by himself he had nobody to go
with what do you call a fish with no
eyes a fish when I found out my toaster
was not waterproof I was shocked
how often do I make chemistry jokes
periodically I actually told one does
the other day there was no reaction
my boss he told me to attach two pieces
of wood together I totally nailed it if
the mushroom was such a fun guy why
didn't they have the party at his house
cuz there wasn't mushroom why did
Cleopatra fall off the swing because
she's dead what's orange and sounds like
parrots carrots the spider has grown
under the keyboard okay I think it's
under control has controls the key what
does Gary Numan would it be when he
grows up Gary Oldman ah everybody must
be Gary Oldman though what's Michelle
Obama's favorite vegetable hi ass
broccoli broccoli right one of the
strongest days of the week Saturday and
Sunday cuz all the rest they're weekdays
what do you call a pretty woman on the
arm of a banjo player a tattoo I don't
know why banjo players I don't know my
friends and I we put on a performance
about puns it was basically just a play
on words why don't the French only use
one egg per omelet cuz in France one egg
is enough what did the shy pebble wish
just that she was a little bolder a
little bolder I look so cute
did you hear David lost his ID in Prague
now we just have to call him Dobb why
was 6 afraid of 7 because 7 has cold
dead eyes when he got a pencil without
LED pointless Beethoven's favorite fruit
how do you make an octopus giggles hen
giggles you gave him tentacles tantek
knock knock who's there interrupting
allo interrupting owl who wider gorillas
have big nostrils big fingers which side
of the chicken has more feathers the
outside horse walks into a bar and the
bartender says why the long face and the
horse says I'm finally realizing that my
alcoholism is driving my family apart
what do you call a man who shaves 20
times a day
barber what did one eye say to the other
eye tween you and me man
something smells never trust an atom
they make up everything I took the shell
up my racing snail because I thought
maybe I'd make it a little faster but if
anything it's more sluggish why do the
Dalek cross the road to enslave humanity
what do you call Santa's little helpers
subordinate clauses what the Hat say to
the hat rack you stay here I'll go on
ahead why would the broom late for work
cause it over swept did you hear oxygen
magnesium are totally going out it's
like OMG did you hear that the tool
antennas got married I heard the
ceremony was kind of terrible what the
reception was awesome what's et short
for so we can fit on a spaceship did you
hear about the new corduroy pillows then
make it headlines my granddad had the
heart of a lion and a lifetime ban from
the Bronx Zoo
sure what are they call primary school
in America elementary my dear Watson
why can't you hear a pterodactyl go to
the bathroom if the P is silent a golden
retriever and an Irish Setter on
vacation the Irish Setter says to the
golden retriever man I just met two
Brazilian dogs and the golden retrievers
like oh how how many is a Brazilian how
do you cook toilet paper it's easy you
just brown it and then you throw it into
the pot two whales walk into a bar one
of them's like
the other ones like man Steve go home
you are drunk
I wasn't sure it was possible but here
we are fifty three jokes in four minutes
later and everybody on Twitter for
suggesting jokes for me you all more
like this I've done a few of these over
the years and John I'll see you on
Tuesday